within the past 30 minutes authorities
in Chicago reported an active shooter at
a Southside hospital now they say
several people have been wounded in that
shooting a list reportedly including a
police officer and a suspect at this our
senior correspondent Mike Tobin has the
latest breaking news tonight from the
scene good evening Mike good evening
Breton we just have confirmation through
Mercy Hospital and they say that the
shooting is over there was a police
officer scouring the hallways here at
Mercy Hospital indication that they felt
the threat was not alleviated but now we
have that confirmation through the
hospital that the shooting the incident
here is over confirmed through Anthony
Guglielmo the Chicago Police spokesman
one police officer has been shot he is
in critical condition he's been
transferred to the University of
hospital Medical Center awaiting an
update from him a possible suspect has
been shot scanner traffic says that
suspect was shot in the face not
confirmed through official channels
there's a lot of discussion about
multiple victims or accounts of two
people dead two people in critical
condition the Chicago Tribune reports
less than six again that's not through
official channels we're still waiting
for that information to be boiled down
what we're hearing from witnesses is
that the gunman focused particularly on
woman one woman standing over her in the
parking lot discharging multiple shots
in her direction a really important like
range I should say that being said we
don't know if this was motivated by a
domestic dispute
if this sadly would fit the pattern that
we have been become accustomed to with
these mass shootings or if it is part of
the violence that you've heard so much
about plaguing the city of Chicago most
of that gun violence is contained to the
south and west sides of the city and we
are on the south side of the city right
now but we just can't make those
connections right now there were 21
shootings over the weekend here in the
city of Chicago so gun violence is still
very much a problem gear we're waiting
on more details about this particular
shooting at Mercy Hospital but again
through the official channels here at
Mercy Hospital the threat is alleviated
the shooting situation is now over
Brett yeah 21 shootings over the weekend
Mike Tobin live on the south side with
the breaking news from Chicago